راح نبدا من اليمن اذا اعلنت اللجنه
الدوليه للصليب الاحمر في اليمن بدا عمليه
تبادل الاسرى بين الحكومه اليمنيه
والحوثيين فيما اكد المتحدث باسم صليب
الاحمر في تصريحاته العربيه ان عمليه
التبادل تشمل 15 رحله خلال اربعه ايام
وستصل الرحلات الى ست مطارات وبحسب الصليب
الاحمر ايضا فان الطائرتين ستدخل يعاني
بالتوازي محملتين باسرى الطرفين وتستغرق
الرحله بين نقطتين الانطلاق والوصول نحو
40 دقيقه
هذا هو افاد مراسل العربيه قبل قليل
باقلاع طائره من مطار عدن الى صنعاء تحميل
125 اسيرا حوسيا وبالتزامن اقلع الطائره
من صنعاء الى عدن وتحمل 35 اسيرا بينهم
وزير الدفاع الاسبق اللواء الركن محمود
الصبيحي وشقيق الرئيس السابق اللواء الروك
الناصر منصور هادي اما عدد اسرى الحوثيين
المفرج عنهم من عدن فهو 249 اسيرا على
دفعتين
من عدم مشاهدينا ينضم الينا مراسله
العربيه ردفان
بدايه كيف تجري عمليات تبادل الاسره بين
الشرعيه والحوثيين والى اي مرحله وصلت حتى
اللحظه
الطائره الاولى من هنا من مطار
اسير حوثي في الوقت نفسي اطلاق الطائره
التي تحمل 35 اسير على راسهم وزير الدفاع
اليمنيه السابق ومحمود الصبحي وكذلك اللغه
ناصر منصور هذه اليمني هذه الدفعه الاولى
او التي
اقنعت قبل قليل ستصل الطائره بعد 40 دقيقه
الى هنا الى عدن الى مطار عدن ثم تصل ايضا
الطائر من المطار بنفس التوقيت المسافه
بينهما 40 دقيقه
ستكون ايضا هناك رحله اخرى
من المتوقع ان تكون الساعه الواحده والنصف
ظهر هذا اليوم والتي ستكون في
الدفعه الثانيه من عدن الى صنعاء والتي هي
124 اسير يكون اجماليين في مطاره عدن يتم
نقلهم الى صنعاء 249 اسير في المقابل يتم
نقل 35 اسير بالدعاء الثانيه الى مسار عدن
ليكون عدد الاسرى التي يتم نقلهم من
الصنعه الى عدد 70 اسير
الاول وهناك حضور طبعا قياده وزاره الدفاع
اشراف مباشر من قياده التحالف قياده
السعوديه
قيادات في بارزه في الدوله في وزاره
الداخليه ومنظمات المجتمع المدني ستكون
هناك اربع رحلات رحلتين من مطار ابها في
المملكه العربيه السعوديه الى الطلعه
ورحنا من صنعاء الى مطار الرياض والتي
تحمل نقل الرئيس نقل عضو مجلس القياده
الرئاسي صارت صالح وايضا شقيق عضو مجلس
القياده صالح وعدد من السعوديه
والسودانيين ايضا رحله اخرى من مطار الى
صنعاء والتي تحمل عدد من اسرار الحوثيين
يوم غدا بعد غدا الاحد ستكون هناك رحله
بين مطار صنعاء مارب مارد الصنعاء والتي
تحمل عدد من اسرار بينهما الاربعه
الصحفيين المحكوم عليهم بالاعدام من قبل
ميليشيات العمليه يتم بحسب ماروشيما اي
عقبات التحالف القياده السعوديه يقدم
الدعم الكبير والتسهيل لكل الصعاب لنجاح
هذه العمليه وهي ايضا هذه العمليه تعتبر
الخطوه الاولى
نتابع مع مشاهدينا هذه الصور التي وصلت
الى العربيه قبل قليل
لاشراف قوات الشرعيه في مطار عدن على
عمليه نقل الاسرى الحوثيين وكما افادوا
رسائل العربيه قبل قليل فقط اقلعت
الطائرتان طائره المطار عدن الى صنعاء
وطائره اخرى ايضا من الصنعه الى عدن طائره
ساعاتنا المتجهه الى صنعاء تحمل 125 اثيرا
حوسيه حوثيا وطائره صنعاء الى عدن تحمل 35
اسيرا بينهم وزير الدفاع الاسبق اللواء
الركن محمود الصبيحي وايضا شقيق الرئيس
السابق اللواء الركن ناصر منصور هذه
المشاهدين متابع معكم هذه الصور التي وصلت
الى قناه العربيه قبل قليل الاشراف قوات
الشرعيه في مطار عدن على عمليه نقل الاسرى
الحوثيين نذكر مشاهدينا ايضا بان
الطائرتين اقلعتا بالتوازي بالمطاري صنعاء
ومطار عدن احداهما تحمل اسرع
تابعينا قوه الشرعيه واسرع اخرين في
الطائره الاخرى المتجهه من عدن الى صنعاء
وتحميل اسرى حوثيين ردفان ما الذي ينتظر
على صعيد استقبال هؤلاء الاسرى بمنفهم من
اسماء بارزه في مطار عدن
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
الاستقبالهم استقبالنا الكبير حاصل بعد
غياب ثمان سنوات الحرب في سجون الاشياء
الاحمر عدم قياده وزاره الدفاع قياده
الشرعيه الدوله
على راسهم وزير الدفاع السابق اللواء
محمود الصبيحي هناك استقبال عام ايضا اخر
من قبائل الصبيع حق خارج مطار عدن في
منطقه الصبيحه لعدم ككل
المحافظات المجاوره وقياده الدوله تستقبل
اليوم العشره وتودع ايضا اسرى الحوثي من
مطار عدم وايضا
الاخرى حتى يتم الافراج
عن باقي الاسرى المتواجدين في سجون
ميليشيات السعوديه ايضا وتبدا عمليه
السلام
كيفيه كما يقول المواطن والقيادات للدوله
والكل على ان لابد من وجود عمليه السلام
حقيقيه كانت الحوثي وكان الكل لا يثق بهذا
ولكن يبدو ان العمليه الان كما قال الصليب
الاحمر اي مشكلات ولا توجد عقبات ان شاء
الله
الشرعيه قال لنا بان لا توجد هناك اي
مشكلات وان بحسب ما رسم لهذا التبادل يتم
الان تنفيذه على ارض الواقع في الطائره
قبل قليل وستصل الطائره من صنعاء الى عدن
ويتم استقبال الوزير السابق وايضا الشقيق
الرئيس
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات